c'est une chasse aux oeufs géante qui a
pris possession du parc municipal le
village samedi 17 avril à trappes
de quoi occuper les enfants en cette
période de vacances scolaires on permet
aux enfants de profiter de ce joli parc
immense que peu de trappistes
connaissent d'ailleurs qu'ils puissent
en profiter en plein air en respectant
les gestes barrières les distances de
sécurité parce qu'on est en période kovy
d'un qu'il faut évidemment être très
attentif à ces aspects et les services
municipaux se sont mobilisés dans
différents services jeunesse sports
centre socioculturel elle les enfants
devaient ramasser dans le parc des jeux
de couleurs objectif reconstituer un
panier de 6 les petites balles qui sont
de la même couleur
d'accord il faudra les mettre dans la
boîte dessus en fait on a mis une petite
étiquette de couleurs qui correspond en
fait aux six couleurs qui doivent
récupérer
donc en fait j'ai ensuite ils font le
parcours dans le parc municipal qui est
séparé en six zones de couleurs pouvoir
amasser un oeuf de couleur vous le
mettez dans la boîte il faut que vous
allez remplir la boîte avec les six
couleurs différentes il manque à la
verte pour les plus grands des questions
de culture générale ont été disposés sur
le parcours avec à la clé en tirage au
sort
j'ai des chaînes on dit qu'il est
l'autre homme ni rupture genève et les
rêves des souches de la leçon sur un
questionnaire les banques une fois sa
mission accomplie chaque au fond et
chant sa voix de l'enfant placé contrat
sachet de chocolats c'est quoi demain à
la maison pour des chocolats carrelage
en colère des chocolats oui parce que tu
as bien travaillé
j'ai dû trouver les plus de 1000 enfants
ont profité de la chasse aux oeufs de
trappes ce week end